[Music]
on this Saturday night Alberta on high
alert this holiday weekend
on the front lines is Flames fuel new
fears there are dry conditions it's it
could fire up anytime the burning crisis
and concerns campers could make it worse
high stakes diplomacy at the G7 the new
unexpected Alliance and Trudeau's
important meeting tomorrow
they're called Forever chemicals because
they last forever from food containers
to clothing a new report highlighting
the hidden dangers in your home
and sticking up for cancer research a
Nova Scotia man's special request to
Sidney Crosby
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us the Wildfire situation in Fox Creek
Alberta is growing desperate the
firefighters in the community 260
kilometers Northwest of Edmonton are
reinforcing their last line of defense
the fire has inched within a kilometer
of the town and it's now threatening
homes and businesses as Blake law
reports in our top story tonight crews
are working around the clock to protect
Fox Creek with everything they have
we work together we always have a
pre-plan with fire on his doorstep Fox
Creek Fire Chief Brian Davidson says
he's as prepared as he can be it's right
across the northern Edge into the west
and into the East right now he's
standing near the main line of defense a
massive cat guard one of many built to
protect the town guessing it's about 100
meters across it's it's big yeah part of
the fire was against our uh our Northern
cat guard and we were able to hold it
right there the eagle complex fire
showed extreme Behavior going into the
weekend the main concern on Saturday was
the wind but so far it's cooperating
yeah we've been lucky they swirled a
couple times as edmontonians will know
and the smoke is is drifted in when the
winds have come from the Northwest but
by and large that line is continuing to
hold there are more than 300 people
assigned to the fire 121 firefighters
from Alberta Ontario New Brunswick and
the U.S are on the ground the military
has sent 4 42 soldiers as well
smoke from Fox Creek and nearly 90 other
fires burning across Alberta can be seen
from space dipping into the United
States and Eastern Canada and with an
unseasonably hot May long weekend
authorities are asking people across the
province to avoid any activities that
could lead to human-caused fires we're
pretty busy with what we've got right
now we don't need to be responding to
any more new wildfires we can help it as
Crews and Fox Creek Shore up their
defenses messages of support the town
adding these words of encouragement from
residents to a digital billboard in the
middle of the evacuated Town hundreds
were sent in I want to go home we all
want to go home but we don't have a home
to go to in Fox Creek Blake law Global
News
to Ukraine next in the critical battle
for bakmut in a video posted online
today by the Russian Wagner Peril
military group its leader claimed
victory of fact moot saying Russian
Fighters have now complete control of
the city now Ukrainian military
officials quickly called those claims
untrue they say the eight months of
fighting is still going on and Ukrainian
troops remain in control of some areas
bakmut has become a symbolically
important Battleground in this war with
casualties on both sides believed to be
in the thousands
and Ukrainian president vlodimir
zielinski's seen stealing arrival at the
G7 Summit in Japan dominated the agenda
in the meeting of global Powers
zielinski once again asked world leaders
for Aid and weapons in Ukraine's fight
for sovereignty and it looks like he's
getting Newfound support from an
unexpected Ally as member nations signal
new efforts to stand up against both
Russia and China Mackenzie gray is in
Japan and has more on the shifting
geopolitical landscape
a red carpet arrival for a man on a
mission Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski has come to Hiroshima to get
more weapons
a call to G7 is ready to heed we have
turned to discussions about improving
the Ukrainian Air Force f-16's fourth
generation fighter aircraft are part of
that mix
foreign
those jets are long-standing zelinski
ask won't be a part of the upcoming
Ukrainian counter-offensive your trading
time required to get the pilots up in
the air but the Ukrainian president
won't go back to Kiev empty-handed Joe
Biden is set to announce a new weapons
package
and zielinski may have an important new
friend Indian president Narendra Modi
says he'll do everything he can to help
Ukraine a change in tone from a key
Global player just a few months ago
Narendra Modi affirmed that his
friendship with Vladimir Putin was
Unbreakable
this needs to change if anything is
going to change in Ukraine G7 members
cleared the deck to meet with zelinski
announcing the final communique a day
earlier than expected the 40-page
document covers a number of issues
including calling on China to follow
conventions around diplomatic activities
and to non-interferent countries
Democratic processes a topic that a
senior Canadian official said the Prime
Minister pushed to include in the memo
the leaders also stated they wanted to
de-risk their economies from Beijing and
diversify with new partners we want to
find solutions to the real challenges
low and middle income countries are
facing today those countries receiving
help from Canada with Justin Trudeau
announcing nearly half a billion dollars
to help develop in countries build
infrastructure and improve food security
a key message when Trudeau met with the
leaders of Vietnam and Indonesia excited
to deepen and strengthen the great
friendship between Canada and Indonesia
to grow our economic ties Trudeau's
biggest one-on-one meeting is likely to
take place tomorrow as the prime
minister is expected to sit down with
Vladimir zielinski for their second ever
in-person meeting pharah Mackenzie gray
and Hiroshima for us tonight thank you
Mackenzie and President Joe Biden is
heading home right after the G7 Summit
canceling the rest of his Asia trip to
focus on America's debt ceiling fight
negotiations are now stalled with only
10 days to go before the U.S hits what's
being called The X date that is the
earliest Point according to the U.S
treasury secretary that the country
could default on its Financial
Obligations which experts say would
spark a potential worldwide economic
meltdown regichini has the latest on
America's debt distress
for a country already sitting on more
than 31 trillion dollars debt America is
skating dangerously close to disaster as
it struggles to find a way to increase
how much it can borrow or risk a
calamitous default it cannot be held
high
by Republicans after days of what was
touted as progress talks broke down on
Friday sending the White House into
damage control with U.S President Joe
Biden cutting short his trip to Asia it
is definitely a subject of Interest here
at the G7 this is not generating alarm
or a kind of vibration in the room if
the debt limit isn't raised the
government won't be able to pay its
military and checks for Social programs
would dry up Republicans who control the
purse strings say they have a budget
that allows an increase in borrowing but
claim the president's team is being
unreasonable when it comes to a big
demand but we can't be spending more
money next year we have to spend lessons
it's not so simple Republicans aren't
fully aligned behind the speaker and
negotiating could create more friction
that could open a path for Democrats to
lure over moderate GOP lawmakers and
pass their own budget with a debt limit
increase we have never defaulted
the last time we came close we lost
credit rating a default could result in
widespread recessions and torpedo Global
markets and with most of Congress
heading into recess experts say a fast
solution could lie within the
Constitution the 14th Amendment uh says
that the validity of the public debt
shall not be questioned Biden has been
receptive to this option and while it's
never been tested legal experts say it
would help pay the bills while the
courts look into it congresses have said
you have to spend a certain amount and
the president and Congress cannot
invalidate those debts with no weekend
negotiations planned the silence is
deafening making the view over the
financial cliff more harrowing Reggie
chikini Global News Washington
Canada's Federal Justice minister is on
the defensive this week fighting off
attacks from conservative leader Pierre
poliev who says the liberal government's
stance on granting repeat offenders bail
is too lenient a common sense
conservative government will reverse
Trudeau's Catch and Release we will
bring in laws that require repeat
violent offenders who are newly arrested
for violence just to stay behind bars
with jail not bail jail not bail until
their trial is done and their sentence
is complete
Paulie Evans says his policies would be
Charter compliant but as Mercedes
Stevenson hears from David lametti on
the west block this week he says the
system is more than a rhyming tagline
do you believe that some of the policies
you've introduced uh bear some
responsibility and that you as a
government bear some responsibility for
that rise in violent crime no not at all
I mean crime policy criminal justice
policy doesn't revolve down to a doesn't
devolve down to a simple silly slogan as
as Mr poliet seems to want to lead
people to believe first of all
um the the statistics are are not as
clear as he claims they are uh there has
been a general decrease over the last 20
years uh in crime
there has been there has been a Spate of
killing a police officers recently as
you pointed out in your introduction and
and that is that is true uh my my
sympathies go out uh to uh the families
of police officers but but also to Law
Enforcement Officers generally we know
we know they have a tough job and so
that's what we're trying to do today is
is attack the problem of repeat violent
offenders but this is a complex problem
it it goes to a number of different
factors in society coming out of a a
very a very uh
unprecedented pandemic which brought
fault lines of of mental health uh and
and other uh challenges to the fore and
so we're dealing with all of that
um the the changes that were made uh
that we have made have them we think
improved the criminal justice system uh
allowing us to concentrate quite frankly
on more serious crimes as opposed to
wasting time and resources on uh on
people who should not be incarcerated is
it fair to say that you've had a change
of heart uh on the issue of bail and
that's why you're now reversing some of
what you'd previously brought in
well if if what you're saying is that
c75 the the first bail bill made it
easier to get bail that's that's just
not true uh we actually made it harder
to get bail for intimate partner
violence so we reverse the onus in part
uh in in those kinds of offenses so it
is a very inaccurate characterization
from from the conservative party in
particular to say that c75 made it
easier to get bailing
and you can watch the full interview
with the Justice Minister tomorrow on
the west block right here on global
Moncton New Brunswick remains graced
with royalty with Princess Anne's visit
in full swing
[Music]
the sister of King Charles attended a
parade celebrating the 175th anniversary
of the eighth Canadian husars Canada's
oldest serving Cavalry Regiment in a
speech she praised their history of
military excellence and enviable
reputation since forming in 1848 and was
appointed as the unit's ceremonial
colonel in Chief in 1972 she will take
part in more anniversary celebrations
for the rest of the weekend
forever chemicals forever banned coming
up the push to eliminate an increasingly
used toxin
we can't see it but there's a silent
threat lurking in our homes an invisible
danger found in things we use every day
forever chemicals and as the name
implies the cancer-causing agents are
doing lasting damage to our health and
the environment
Ottawa is now looking at limiting or
Banning these chemicals and as Brittany
Rosen reports experts say it can't come
soon enough
from the clothing you wear to the
non-stick cookware you may use to
scramble your eggs poly floral kill
substances or pifas for short can be
found just about anywhere that now
includes your body they're called
Forever chemicals because they last
forever and what makes them more of a
concern yet
is that they stick around in the
environment for example in our drinking
water a new health Canada draft report
indicates the chemicals have seeped into
Canadians blood samples the data
underscores the adverse effects the
toxic chemicals have on both human
health and Wildlife there's sound
evidence to show that an exposure to
some of the pfas class can cause types
of cancer pifas are in a class of over 4
700 toxic human-made substances they can
be found in an ever-growing list of
products including food packaging
firefighter foam and repellents the
report says firefighters and Indigenous
adults and youth face the most exposure
Canada's minister of environment tweeted
only diamonds should be forever not
human-made substances that are polluting
the environment Health Canada is looking
for public input as it proposes to list
the entire class of chem chemicals as
toxic under the Canadian Environmental
Protection act now that label would then
allow the government to enact measures
like a ban similar to what Ottawa did
with single-use plastics
it would be the first time Canada has
considered designating an entire class
of chemicals as toxic as opposed to
individual substances the real benefit
to dealing with a whole class of
chemicals is that we're not saying that
you can't use one thing and then that
one thing is slightly tweaked and
replaced with a variation that can be as
problematic well experts say it's a step
forward some remain critical as to
whether there's enough evidence to
suggest the designation is necessary the
public will have 60 days to weigh in on
the proposed changes Brittany Rosen
Global News Toronto
I had revolutionizing emergency medicine
a Quebec doctors Touch of a button
solution that has caught the attention
of the Canadian space agency
an app to help emergency room doctors
save their most critical patients
designed in Montreal is now helping to
save lives in dozens of countries around
the world the Revolutionary technology
May soon help those in the next Frontier
as well space Gloria henriquez shows us
how it works and why there's so much
excitement around it
when doctors deal with an emergency like
this there's little room for maneuver or
for error lives are on the line it's
it's super tough In the Heat of the
Moment to do absolutely no mistakes to
help staff deal with that critical first
hour of resuscitation Dr Lemaire created
an App Health practitioners no longer
have to consult books the internet and
then make complicated calculations many
times over on a piece of paper easy
Reese's has all the tools needed to
figure out appropriate treatment for
patients in the same place we're talking
about a drug dosing equipment selection
some checklist for procedure just to
offload our brain so we can focus on the
patient 30 volunteers have been working
to input all the necessary information
from nurses to Pharmacists and emergency
doctors like Jean Francois it's really
just a great tool that helps the whole
team and really rapidly you can have a
reliable calculation there are now
nearly 5 000 users in 29 different
countries around the world
and now the app has the chance of
improving care beyond the confines of
planet Earth easy Reese's is a finalist
in the Canadian space agency's deep
space Healthcare challenge it's a
competition seeking technologies that
can help improve access to care in
remote Canadian communities and to
cruise on deep space missions and
because the challenges are so similar
well the technological solutions are
probably also very similar it's like
super super exciting so we get funding
and then we get a chance to collaborate
with the Canadian space agency so it
would give us the money and the leverage
to make this dream happen distribute the
app as broadly as possible and maybe
someday you know help an astronaut it
needs enrolled to Mars that's Dr
lemare's true final frontier Gloria
Enriquez Global News
[Music]
next turning hockey sticks into hope
this Craftsman's One of a Kind chair and
why he needs Sydney Crosby for his next
big goal
Brittany Greiner has made her first WNBA
start since being freed from a Russian
prison
her team the Phoenix Mercury opened the
season against the Los Angeles Sparks
last night in front of an excited crowd
that included U.S vice president Kamala
Harris Greiner missed the 2022 season
while detained in Russia for nearly 10
months on drug charges after the game
Griner told reporters it's nice to be
back in the court
I appreciate everything a little bit
more
you know all the little small moments
that you know I used to just like oh I'm
so tired oh I don't want to go to
practice today or oh this that
I think that that has changed honestly
you know um
just appreciating everything because you
know tomorrow's not guaranteed you don't
know what it's going to look like
Griner scored 18 points but Phoenix lost
94-71 prior to the home opener the last
time she played in a WNBA game was in
the 2021 finals more than 570 days ago
Canada's hockey teams may be out of the
playoff
s hockey is still a national Pastime a
Nova Scotia man has found a way to bring
people together over their Love of the
Game crafting furniture from retired
sticks and now he's asking for a little
star power for a particularly special
piece Shelly Steves has the story
behind this shed door lies a passion for
hockey and health that's nothing to
shake a stick at I got a Strong
Addiction
Martin Ben was shed in Lower Sackville
is decorated to the rafters with
discarded hockey sticks in this room
orders probably between 12 to 1300
easily his passion for fabricating with
old wooden sticks started about 20 years
ago when he made his first hockey stick
chair for his son to raise money for a
local charity I never sell anything
everything I make I donate all the time
big park bench and this year the cause
hits closer to home inspired by his wife
who over the past few years has beat the
odds overcoming three kinds of cancer
she had treatments and is doing very
well and
it's an angel so now we we're we're in a
process of giving back there's just so
many so many people who have either
lived it or
love someone who's lived it and
yeah
the fact that he's giving back it so
yep
that love and passion has gone into his
latest auction item carefully crafted
with the same kind of old-fashioned
wooden sticks used by one of the best
players in the world I was very
particular on making sure that you could
see his name at many different places if
you look on the side it says Sydney
Crosby their goal is to track down
Crosby next time he's home in Nova
Scotia and have him sign the chair to
boost up the bid all of which will be
donated to a cancer fundraiser if we can
get Sydney to sit in it we're going to
go read the money to write for cancer
the couple says Crosby has an open
invitation to visit the stick shed come
on over
can help someone like Darlene beat the
odds it's worth a shot Shelly Steve's
Global News Lower Sackville Nova Scotia
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm foreign Aster on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us hope you're having a
peaceful long weekend tonight's York
Canada is White Rock British Columbia
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
[Music]
thank you